hey there YouTube welcome to ask a
career coach my name is Martin oh I
think I spoke too soon hey there YouTube
welcome to ask a career coach my name is
Martin McGovern and we are going live
this Thursday March 21st we do have a
little bit of a snafu with the YouTube
live links so you'll be getting another
link sent to you via email very soon and
I'm going to just give a little bit more
time today for people to join the call
so that we can make sure that everyone
who has the old link it gets the new one
and can transition over and make sure
that everyone gets to join us today so
I'm going to pause real quick just so we
can get all of the technical stuff set
and working correctly and then we will
jump on in to all the questions that you
have all the great career questions that
are on your mind and we'll get into them
today all right so it looks like we've
got a couple of people filtering in for
those of you who are who got the right
link who saw the right posting give us a
shout in the comments were you joining
from we got someone from Spain already
give us a shot of where you're joining
from I'm in gloomy Chicago today it is
been quite a rainy week out here so
where you all joining from all right
we're gonna give a few minutes for folks
to transition over to the new link
appreciate your patience
[Music]
all right I'm just making sure that the
right link is going out to everyone
today so I appreciate your patience as
we get this live chat started thank you
all again for joining us and finding the
correct link and getting over here and
if you have career questions please
start putting them in the chat we'll be
collecting those throughout the hour and
we'll be making sure that we cover
everything that's on your mind when it
comes to your career development all
right we got North Carolina rainy as
well thank you for commiserating
we got India all right and again for all
of you joining thank you for your
patience as we get the correct link link
out to everybody we'll be getting into
the first question here which is going
to be how do I follow up during the jobs
search it's a big question that is on a
lot of people's minds and I've seen it
go a lot of different ways both positive
and negative so we'll be diving into
that as well give any other questions
we're evolving communication style
during the interview or during the job
search process you know how to email how
to follow-up how to reach out on
LinkedIn what other questions do you
have in regards to communication during
the job search we can dive into all
those questions today put them in the
chat and Kelsey will be sending those my
way so we can really dive in make sure
that all your questions are answered and
you're on the right path in your job
search
ooh we got Houston the Sun is out and it
is gorgeous huh
too bad you're inside I feel you on that
one when it is sunny in Chicago and the
lake
right there it's it's tough to stay
inside Argentina thanks for joining us
all right looks like people are finding
the right link and getting over here
again I appreciate you all joining us
today please add your questions into the
chat and we will be getting to them
throughout the hour
we're just waiting a little bit for
everyone to join us for those who are
new here my name is Martin McGovern I'm
a career adviser at Udacity and you've
probably gotten a lot of emails and
different things for me over the over
the past couple years as I do work on a
lot of the different products and a lot
of the different things that we're
working on in order to help you
understand the job search and really
figure out how to navigate it in the
easiest and and in a most efficient way
and so what we can talk about today are
a lot of the you know best practices a
lot of the communication styles how do
you promote yourself how do you connect
with people network interview all those
different things I don't have a
background in in development or
programming so some of the hyper
technical stuff we won't be able to go
as deep on but you know I've worked with
lots and lots of students so we do it we
can touch on some of the technical
topics as well I have a background in
marketing so if you have any questions
about how to promote yourself how to use
social media anything like that
we can definitely dive on in so thank
you again for joining us today
we're gonna be diving into our first
question in just a moment here we're
getting that new link out to everyone so
that all of you can get your questions
answered and of course this will be
recorded so we can come back and watch
it at any time all right
so I'm gonna jump into that very first
question how do I follow up during the
job hunt this is a really interesting
question and it's something that starts
not in the tactics of following up but
in the mindset that we have when we're
job searching
typically the mindset that we have is
one of anxiety right we are sending out
job applications we're not hearing back
we're getting ghosted we're hearing back
getting
our hopes up and then having the hopes
dashed when we find out it's not the
right fit or they went was a different
candidate there's a lot of ups and downs
in the job search it's a real
rollercoaster for most people and when
we have an on that rollercoaster for a
while we start to get a little bit you
know hypersensitive to the
communications or receiving we start to
assume people aren't getting back to us
because they don't like us or they don't
they don't think that you know we're
important and and we get really in our
heads about with with negativity we just
get really negative when it comes to
communicating and a lot of communication
is also very me focused so it's you know
it's we want to be validated right so we
what we need to do is take a step back
separate ourselves from the
communications a little bit and realize
that although the job search is very
personal to us it's actually business to
everyone else it is not personal so if
someone hasn't responded in a week if
someone hasn't you know been keeping you
up-to-date every single day about every
little thing that's going on it has
nothing to do with you know us it has
all to do with them and we're there at
chances are the person who you're
interviewing with the person who you're
waiting to hear back from this is just
one part of their job this might not
even be their primary job this might be
something that they were you know asked
to do in addition to their already heavy
workload so you know just put yourself
in their shoes they're working 40 50 60
hours a week then they realize oh no
we're short-staffed we got to get
someone in here all right let's start
interviewing they post it online they
get hundreds of applicants right they
start interviewing that takes time out
of their day they have hundreds of
people that they suddenly have to keep
in touch with that they haven't had to
keep in touch with before
that's pretty overwhelming right and so
they're going to lose contact they're
going to lose touch it is good to follow
up so that they remember you so that you
you know jump back to the top of their
mind
when the time is right but we just need
to realize that you know none of it is
personal if they haven't gotten back to
you in a week it's probably because
they're overwhelmed if they go sit it's
probably because you know they picked a
candidate and they just didn't have time
to send fifty to a hundred I'm sorry
you're not right for the role evals
right and then of course they have
automated systems at some companies but
we get those and we get upset about
those as well
so we really got to have a little bit
more empathy when it comes to the job
search even though we're going through a
real rough roller coaster on our side
right and we want them to have empathy
for us but in order to get empathy you
have to give it and so what we really
want to do when we're thinking about the
job search and we're not hearing back
about things is take a step back calm
ourselves down and ask what is the best
thing that I can do to help them make a
decision how often did they need to hear
from me in order to not you know not
having them forget who you are because
they are probably talking to a lot of
people but also not overwhelm them or
push them too quickly so what we want to
do and this is just a rule of thumb this
is not by any means a scientific measure
or anything like that but the way I like
to think about follow-ups is 24 hours
one week two weeks four weeks stop and
what that means is from the last point
of contact that you had with someone
send a follow-up that says thank you I'm
really excited to continue the
conversation and send that within the
next 24 hours you should always send a
thank-you within 24 hours of the last
conversation you had now in that email
you'll want to either ask them what
their timeline is or you'll want to say
like I'll follow-up in a week or two if
I don't hear back something like that
then you know you'll say thank you
you'll ask about the timeline a week
will go by we won't hear back okay okay
it's been a week we're starting to get
anxious how come they haven't gotten
back to us
take a breath a week from that 24-hour
follow up you can send out your first
like week after follow you can send out
a follow-up so we have initial meeting
within 24 hours we've sent to follow up
a week later we have in her back we're
gonna check in in that one week check-in
we can say something like hey checking
in on the timeline wondering if there's
anything you need from me
is there anything else I can do to help
you know move things forward and you can
ask them again what's the timeline
things like that you could also get
creative you could share like an article
that you found that relates to their
business some new news that happened in
their company that you think would be
interesting to share there's a lot of
interesting things if you say hey I was
just thinking about you think about the
conversation that we had you know this
thing popped up it reminded me of what
we were talking about curious to know
what the if there's any updates to the
timeline and let me know if there's
anything you need from me at this time
so that's at one week all right so we
send our one week follow-up what ends up
happening is we don't hear back in three
days and people start getting itchy they
start wanting to send another follow-up
that week how come you haven't gotten
back to me I don't want Friday to come
and go and have to wait a whole another
weekend sitting in this anxiety and in
this stress right so then what what what
people will typically do is they'll send
another one and then maybe another one
and then maybe another one I was
actually working with someone and they'd
sent like two or three follow-ups within
a week and like tried actually I was
working with someone who went really
overboard with this they were sending
follow-ups they were calling they sent a
follow-up email in the morning called
someone's phone in the afternoon and
then the next day went into the office
to try and catch the person at their
desk the person wasn't in they were out
to lunch needless to say they didn't get
the job
it's a bit too much it's a bit
overwhelming and I know it can get
stressful when you're waiting on an
offer when you're waiting on an answer
when you've got all these other things
in the air but remember we don't want to
get too hyper focused on any one job we
want to keep our options open and we
want if you feel that stress happening
instead of following up ten times with
the company you're already talking to
apply to three more jobs bringing in
some new opportunities spread out your
anxiety basically so that you're not
ever too hyper focused on any one thing
so you've got the initial point of
contact the 24-hour follow-up thank you
the one-week follow-up and what's next
two weeks four weeks six weeks stop so
basically we're just getting exponential
here you don't want to be overburdening
them so if it's been two weeks since the
last time you talk to them
just shoot him an email and say hey you
know it's been a couple of weeks haven't
heard back is this role are you still
you know are you still looking for help
filling this role I'm still very excited
about the position and we'd love to
continue the conversation and then
suggest a time when next week or two
weeks from or yeah we will later this
week or next week work for you in order
to jump back on a call this might be
able to reinvigorate that conversation
but as we know quite often they won't
respond to that one all right so what do
we do we put one more week two more
weeks three more weeks four more weeks
right and again this isn't science maybe
you follow up in two weeks maybe you
follow up in three but if you're getting
to the point where you've sent three or
four follow-ups and they're not getting
back to you you know I would say it's
more important to put that effort
towards another role than to get too
hung up on any one position so you know
rule of thumb here and I'll just stop
there the rule of thumb here is
definitely send a follow-up within 24
hours if you haven't heard back within a
week of that follow-up send another if
you haven't heard back within two weeks
of that follow-up send another and then
start using your emotional intelligence
to understand whether or not this is
going to move forward or not if it's
been four or five weeks since you've
last chatted with them you know there's
other opportunities out there that we
can chase so that's kind of the rule of
thumb around following up during the job
hunt but of course there's a lot of
other things that we have to keep in
mind how do we communicate
are we being me focused or them focused
I focused or them focused are we writing
paragraph emails are we writing short
emails that they can actually read
quickly and go oh yeah I got to do that
right a lot of times people just forget
so we always want to be writing with
excitement with curiosity with a
collaborative mindset and you want to be
saying I'm here to help how can I help
just ask how can I help you know if they
need is there anything you need from me
in order to move this along and those
you know those questions typically will
get answered all right so that is the
intro here how do you follow up during
the job hunt now we're gonna open it up
for your questions it looks like we've
got a number of the people who had
signed up to sign to get over here to
the new link so very happy that you've
all gotten over here to join us now that
we have you here put your questions in
the chat and Kelsey will be sending them
my way so that we can dig into all of
your questions today we've got a couple
coming in but we could use some more so
anything that's on your mind whether
it's in regards to following up
communicating interviews networking
cover letters resumes what is on your
mind today how can we help you improve
your job search and get more responses
and get more interviews and get that job
let us know your questions all right
we're going to dig into the first one
like Krishna the question here is a
recruiter reached out to me on LinkedIn
about a position and my contact
information I responded with my
information and a question that I have
not heard back on was that the right
thing to say if not what should I have
responded with curious to know what the
question was the you asked if you could
put that in the chat what was the
question that you asked in the email
some questions are great to ask some
sort of distract from what we're trying
to get to and a key thing that I want to
keep in mind when we're writing emails
is what is the goal of your email this
is something we don't typically think
about a lot of times when I'm talking to
people and they're sending the follow-up
emails their goal is to get the job an
email is not going to get you the job an
email is going to either be a reminder
it's going to be a conversation about
scheduling it's going to be a you know
sharing of a resource if you like
include a link to something really think
about what the call-to-action in your
email is and this is a marketing thing
if a company sent you an email and there
was no call to action what would you do
with that email you would archive it or
delete it you wouldn't take any action
so if you send an email to someone and
you sign off by saying let me know what
works for you or I'm looking forward to
hearing back or any of those things what
does that person supposed to do with
that information are they supposed to
schedule something now schedule
something are they supposed to send you
something not send you something right
so we really need to think about our
clear call to action our CTA so it looks
like for this one you asked when you can
expect the call you ask because your
student and have busy hours all right
awesome so this is this is a good one
because I think what we need to think
about is when we're asking when to
expect the call what we're doing is
we're giving them homework we're saying
when can you schedule a call with me and
then they're gonna say oh I don't know
Tuesday at 3:00 and you're gonna say
well I've class at Tuesday at 3:00 well
now we're in a weird position now
they're haggling for our time rather
than us trying to be accommodating for
them so here's one thing you can do to
help a recruiter and keep in mind you
want to bring empathy to the job search
so if you're going in and you're like
why isn't this recruiter giving me a job
which I'm not saying you are but that is
a perspective that I sometimes hear if
we go in with that mindset what's going
to end up happening is that they're
gonna you know recruiters are working
with hundreds of people they just don't
have time to you know be shuffling
through try and figure things out they
need answers they need clarity they need
concrete steps to move forward so here's
what to think about in your email what
you know one way we could break it down
is by saying you know you asked them to
provide a time of when they might be
available now if they did that and you
were busy during that time now you're in
a weird back-and-forth so what you want
to do instead is give them times that
you're available so that they can make
an easy decision at the end of the day
when you're when you're trying to
communicate with anyone when you're
trying to get a conversation it sounds
like that the CTA you're trying to get
to is a one-on-one conversation with
this recruiter about that role make it
as easy as possible for them give them a
series of times or windows of times that
you know you're open so that all they
have to do is say who that one yes if we
can make our emails so easy to respond
to that I can respond with a simple
ye-es
yes I don't have to do any research do
any homework do anything like that I can
just say yeah that sounds good great
I'll talk to you then we are low
whirring friction and making it easier
for them to talk to us so let's keep
that in mind so one way you could have
rephrased it and I actually think you
did a pretty good job with Gmail but one
way you could have rephrased it is hey
next week I'm free between one and three
on Monday between four and six on
Tuesday and between 9:00 and 10:00 a.m.
on Wednesday are you able to jump on a
call during any of those times now all
they have to do is say yes I am able to
or no I'm not able to and now you've got
a very clear next step so when you send
your next follow up to them be more
clear say hey I'm free on Wednesday
between these times would you be willing
to jump on a call and discuss the
position at let's say 1:00 p.m. let me
know if that works for you excited to
continue the conversation boom you are
moving in the right direction thank you
so much for your question I think it's
really nuanced and there's a lot to it
but we're all here learning we're all
here trying to improve so you know they
reached out to you that means they they
think that your background or your
experience is interesting I'm also
curious how long it's been since you
sent that email how long it's been since
you've heard back if it's been a week
send another one see how they're doing
all right we're gonna jump it in the
next question here
ilianna asks how long does it normally
take for us to hear back from a company
so we can move on to another job search
this is a great question all right so
the tough answer is that there is no
normal the job search is not really a
science at the end of the day
it's interpersonal communication and
interpersonal communication has you know
themes and and some things that you can
predict but for the most part it's
pretty unpredictable you know you could
say the same thing to two different
people one person thinks it's hilarious
the other person thinks it's offensive
right that's the world we live in so
when you're thinking about how long is
it going to take to hear back from this
company truth of the matter is it could
be immediately they could be very on top
of their game you know it could be a
very efficient large company that has
very strict rules of how quickly they
need to respond it could be a very high
energy startup that is very quick to
respond it could also be a one-person
small consultancy and they take weeks to
get back you know I mean I was in a
situation a while back where you know I
was expecting a response I was expecting
a call from someone it's just a
networking thing but what ended up
happening was you know I was like oh
well let's chat this day they needed to
reschedule I said this day then all of a
sudden nothing just radio silence for
like a month and a half and I'm like you
know me a decade ago would be all
offended like oh this person blew me off
right but now it's like I don't know
they probably got busy maybe they have
like family issues maybe something came
up
if you if you just take the mindset just
take the mindset that like there's a
reason that's probably not related to
you it's not always about you so it can
take a while let's just put it that way
it can take a while be ready for it to
take a while expect it to take a while
and then be pleasantly surprised when
they respond quickly might be a good way
think about it the second part of your
question you said when are we gonna hear
back so we can move on to another job
search I don't think we should wait we
should never be stopping our job search
when we are searching for jobs this
happens all the time someone gets a fish
on the hook right and they go oh my gosh
I might get this job from that moment
where you think oh my gosh I might get
this job you might have four or five
more interview
you might have a week between each
interview you might have two weeks to
get an offer it might be another month
and a half away and what ends up
happening is that we stop all other job
search pursuits we stop applying two
things we stop responding to things we
stop networking and we focus all of our
energy on this one thing and it drives
us crazy because it's great when they
have emailed us and it's terrible when
we're waiting and it's great when they
email us and it's terrible when we're
waiting and then suddenly we find out
after four or five weeks oh no I didn't
get that job and now everything else is
at zero
there's no networking opportunities that
you have on a calendar there's no people
that you're talking to there's no jobs
you've applied for in your pipeline this
happens in sales all the time when
people get too focused on like the one
client that they're trying to close and
they stop filling the top of the funnel
suddenly that client pulls out and they
have a month where they have to rebuild
everything from scratch never stop
applying never stop networking even when
you've got a fish on the hook and you
think you're gonna reel it in if you
ever I don't really watch fishing but I
have seen stuff on like Instagram where
they've you know they're catching the
fish over here but they've got like four
more poles on the boat just sitting in
the water over here just in case right
if that fish gets away they turn around
and grab the other pole so I wouldn't
ever wait to hear back when you're
waiting to hear back use that energy use
that time to start putting more
companies into the top of the filter or
I've got some great questions coming in
thank you all so much for sharing all
right I'm Tara
pronouncing name so I apologize if I
mispronounced some names here today if
you have resources of how I can learn
I'm trying to learn learn how to
pronounce things better but we have a
question here from Natasha the FIR the
question here is what is the best way to
find connections if I'm looking for a
job in another country I'm in Germany
and looking for work in Singapore all
right hmm
all right so the best thing you can do
when you're gonna make a location change
is route you know use LinkedIn to your
advantage use Twitter to your advantage
use Instagram and anywhere else that
people are posting things from that
country to your advantage
probably LinkedIn is the easiest way to
go what you want to do is you want to go
to the people search and in the people
search you can filter by a lot of
different things industry job title
location etc so you're gonna definitely
want to filter by location potentially
filter by job title and I think you type
that into a box there and then you'll
get a list of all the people who have
that job title in Singapore great now
you've got a hundred people let's say
who live in Singapore who work as I
don't know a data scientist if that's
what you're into what you can do is you
can find their email there's a lot of
websites like find that dot email
there's another one that I was just
using the other day and I'm blanking on
the name of it but if anyone else has
like Yellow Pages for emails how to find
people those emails put them in the chat
and and help each other out but find
that email will for sure work for some
of you find their email and reach out to
them say hey I'm moving to Singapore
from Germany and I'm looking to break
into this industry I'm looking to break
into jobs in this area you're doing that
and it looks like you're doing a really
good job would you be open to jumping on
skype and chatting about your
experiences I'd love to learn more about
the city I'd love to learn more about
the job you know network that's out
there you know and I actually did this
when I moved to Texas I reached out to a
bunch of people in Texas and actually
visited
for a week and tried to meet as many
people as possible some conversations
were about the job market some
conversations are about where to eat and
by the time I moved to Texas I actually
had like all these different stars of
great places to eat when I would get
down there so I was like oh I can't wait
to come back and you know buy you a taco
you know thank you for your help and so
that's probably the best way to do it
use the tools that we have at hand to
find people that live in that area and
then just ask for their opinions ask for
their advice if you ask for advice you
might find a job
it's it's actually pretty interesting
how giving people can be because they
get excited about their city they like
it when people are moving there they
want to live in a place that's like cool
and and exciting and people want to move
there so you know you're you're being a
you know you're making them feel good as
well as you're asking for help all right
our next question is from Aisha what is
the best way to convince employers in a
cover letter that you are a great fit if
you feel you don't have all the
requirements that they're looking for
mmm this is a good one so a couple of
things that you want to think about is
the first thing let me break this down a
couple different ways all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna reiterate the question
and I'm gonna break it down what's the
best way to convince employers in a
cover letter that you are a great fit if
you feel you don't have all the
requirements they are looking for for
the job
all right number one you don't have all
the requirements that are looking for
this is an interesting one because
typically and when we're looking at job
boards and we're looking at job listings
we feel like we need to have 100% of the
things that they've put in that job
listing when the truth of the matter is
you really only need like 60 to 70% you
got to think of a job listing more as a
wish list this is something that the
person who works at that company pieced
together from a bunch of different other
job listings and and filled out and
filled out saying if we could get
someone that had everything we would but
they know that there's very few people
in the world that actually have all of
those skills and experiences they know
that there's no way they're gonna find
someone who can code in every single
language and who has a masters and a PhD
and who has all those different things
who has 30 years of experience but is
also young enough and and and spry
enough to like know every new technology
that's coming out those people just
there is no perfect candidate so there
is also no role that is perfect for you
so if you're about 60 to 70 percent
qualified I'd say go for it give it a
shot and try and meet some people have
that company to see what things on that
job listing are actually real and what
things are kind of like you know pipe
dreams you might find out that they put
I don't know you need to know Python in
in the listing but they barely use it I
don't know you know you might find out
a lot of or like if you're in marketing
you might find that like social media
experience is a plus but you your actual
role will never touch social media who
knows so if you feel like you don't have
other requirements take a step back
because you probably have most of the
requirements and that's really what you
want to double down on in your cover
letter you want to really showcase the
requirements that you do hit and the
ones that you will be able to fulfill so
what's the best way to convince
employers in a cover letter that you're
a great fit I think the shorter cover
letters are working better these days
than the old long-form ones so I was
actually just looking at a couple the
other day and you know they're super
long they're big blocks of text and if
you've ever gotten an email that's more
than like three or four paragraphs long
you don't read that thing you're like
skim through archive right so what you
want to do in your cover letter at least
this is my opinion on it is you want to
start by talking about what they do
that's exciting
your company is working towards these
amazing goals you're trying to automate
you know build autonomous driving cars
that will you know reduce harm and
improve emissions and you know make the
world a better place to drive in then in
the second paragraph you want to talk
about how your history will help them
achieve those ambitious goals so my
background in the automotive industry
and programming has makes me a great
candidate to help you achieve these
goals you know I've worked with these
companies and these technologies and I'm
really excited to work with you to
continue improving and help you get to
where you need to be with your software
and then the last paragraph you talk
about how together you're gonna build
some great things so them us and we and
so that's how I like to break it down in
in just a conceptual way of course it'll
look different for everyone
but conceptually you say you're really
doing amazing things
my background can help you keep doing
those amazing things together I can't
wait to bring value to your team so we
can accomplish this stuff together
looking forward to continuing the
conversation thank you for your time and
consideration so on so
for it so that's probably the best way
to double down on and showcase that
you're the best fit and then of course
you know 67% if you've got most of the
qualifications give it a shot hmm
Sanjeev do you have any advice on how to
track different positions I have applied
to while going through the job search
awesome
question this is actually a first no
one's asked this question before I
really appreciate it um there are a lot
of different ways a lot a lot a lot of
different ways to track your job search
and the sad thing is most people aren't
tracking it at all which means they're
forgetting to follow up they're
forgetting what they've even applied to
they're applying to the same job
multiple times they're planning to
multiple jobs at the same company
multiple times it's a mess the job
search is messy and the hard part about
it is you've got to find the system that
works for you
now what can you do personally I think
Google Google Spreadsheets Google sheets
I believe it's called
that's my favorite way to do it I create
my own spreadsheet I put all the jobs
that I'm applying to all the and I break
it down to this company and then the
website the job listing and then the
link to the job listing I tend to copy
or screenshot the job listing because
it'll disappear someday and you don't
want to lose the content that's on that
page the date applied the resume or
cover letter that you included maybe you
save that in a Google Drive separately
the contact that you have at that
company and you should always have a
contact at a company if you don't have
one start networking start reaching out
to people who work there their email
address the last time you followed up
with them and so on and so forth you can
kind of customize it to what you need
and what you do there is you can
actually as your pipe things start
pulling out trends oh this is oh and
maybe even industry these are the
industries I'm interested the job titles
I'm interested in and every day you get
up and you reference that spreadsheet
and you go who do I need to followup
with today ok it's been a week since I
sent that one so I'm gonna follow up
here
what new companies can I add to this
list and you just keep building on it
that's how I like to do it I like to
build Google sheets however that's not
everyone's preference some people prefer
to do it other ways I've seen people do
it in a word doc I think that's a pretty
pretty tough to keep organized way to do
it but you know to each their own I've
seen people just do it in like folders
on their desktop or their Google Drive
and they just save everything in
screenshots and so on put it into
folders people like to use their email
also think that's a terrible way to do
it because you know boomerang only goes
so far
boomerang is a way to like remind
yourself of past emails but you know
that that's typically what people do
it's not very efficient so I would
definitely pick a spreadsheet over that
and then there are a litany of different
applications out there that are trying
to solve this problem I believe job
track was one that was really popular
I'm not quite sure what the status is of
that right now there are there's just so
many different apps out there so if you
just Google like job tracking apps
you'll find a lot of great resources
take a look at the reviews every time I
try to use those I find them to be more
complicated than helpful so I typically
always go back to the Google spreadsheet
but again I'm not everyone so whatever
works for you make it work but
definitely do some googling find some
job tracking stuff that's out there or
build your own spreadsheet and then the
key thing here is I just I'm super happy
that you're thinking about this most
people don't think about it so pat
yourself on the back and thank you for
bringing up that question it's really
really really important all right
mmm-hmm our next question is from javi I
am 46 and I spent many years in
managerial positions now I want to move
into a technical data science role not
the typical career path give any tips to
help me out hmm trying to think where to
start on this one all right so it is
awesome that you have a background of
managerial work because that is very
there's so many skills that come out of
that that are relatable and transferable
to what you're going to do so you can
manage a project if you can manage
people you can manage a project right so
it's great that you have that experience
you need to own it and you need to
showcase it you need to tell the story
of how that relates to what you want to
do next can you manage time can you
manage people can you manage processes
can you build solutions not just
technical solutions but also process
solutions around the technical solutions
because everyone needs process so start
putting together the story about how
your background and your new interests
work together to solve company problems
not just the big ones that the company's
trying to do like build autonomous cars
but also the little ones like increase
efficiency of their team you know make
sure that projects don't get stalled all
these other things that are going on now
you want to move into a technical data
science role you're right it's not a
typical career path so what we want to
do is we want to find people who are
working in that role talk to them get to
know how they broke in what was their
first job what do they like about it
what about that industry that company is
different than other industries and
other companies maybe they've worked in
the field for a while and have seen a
few different perspectives again go to
LinkedIn and do a people search and type
in data science and type in your
location and you should be able to find
a lot of people in your area they could
get coffee with to really sort of get an
insider's view into what they do day to
day so that you can basically tell your
story better and make sure that when
you're interviewing you're hitting on
the points that they need to hear and
you're communicating effectively so they
know you're not just good for the job
you're
for the culture for the fit for
everything I hope that helps maybe
there's some people in the chat here who
are in data science roles or working
towards data science roles or know
people who work in data science and you
can all network with each other and help
each other out alright our next question
is from Diane recruiters are reaching
out with jobs that I'm not skilled in
dotnet Java etc how do I get my actual
skills noticed for those opportunities
I'm a career changer hmm this is a great
question Diane I think one of the
interesting things about recruiters is
sometimes they're playing a numbers game
now I'm not a recruiter so I don't know
all the ins and outs of how they do this
but if you're getting emails that said
that are unrelated to what you do you
know I get some of those too you know
you just kind of have to ignore them
like there's just a lot of spam that
exists in the world and so if there
there's a few things you can do one
ignore arm to respond and say hey that's
actually not my focus what I am really
good at are these things and now they
can update their software and make sure
that those things are highlighted so
they reach out to you with the correct
opportunities and then the other thing
you can do is take a look at your online
presence Google yourself put your resume
and Linkedin into a into a word
generator and see what pops up what are
the things that you are showing up for
in keyword searches in SEO things like
that and if you really want to make a
shift if you really want to change the
way you're perceived online what you
need to do is you need to take control
take ownership of your online presence
own your URL your website write or share
or comment on articles on LinkedIn and
elsewhere that are related to the
roles that you want to be doing so
whatever the thing is that you want to
be noticed for you should be posting
about it
articles comments tweets if you can
write your own stuff you can create
videos like all this stuff helps get you
known for these things right
I started in marketing I work in career
development I still do some marketing
but most of my content is career related
so that's what I'm becoming known for
and so that is a good way to think about
it
highlight the skills that you want
highlighted in your summary of your
LinkedIn so that they see that first
make sure the skills section in your
LinkedIn has the right skills in it make
sure the experience that you have listed
references the things that you want to
be known for and and start interacting
just start utilizing social media in the
internet in the way that it was designed
to be used which is to push you up
according to activity around the topics
that you're most act that's like the
whole algorithm right if you interact
with things they think that that's what
you do and they push you up higher in it
so if you think about like now it's a
bad example because they don't really
link websites like that anymore but the
more you talk about the things you want
to be doing the closer you'll get to be
able to do those things thank you for
your question that was really good one
all right we got a few more questions in
ten more minutes I'm going to try and
get through all of them alright pradeep
i want to apply to an internship at a
big company but i have no experience
what can I do this is a hotly debated
one so you say you have no experience
and the first thing I want to challenge
is that idea of no experience is it no
experience doing that exact role is it
no experience meaning you haven't ever
had a job is it no experience meaning
you don't have any education background
or a job or experience with their role
you probably have some sort of
experience some sort of work that you've
done that might have relatable might
have a relatable skillset
but here's what you really need to think
about at the end of the day you want to
work at whatever company this is or that
whatever industry this is or whoever
that person is you want to work for
right and you're trying to get into the
internship stage well the easiest thing
to do and not everyone agrees with this
but the easiest thing to do because you
want to work in an internship is just
offer to be a free intern give them a
trial period I'll do I'll intern for
free for the next month or two and if
you like my work we can bring me on as a
contractor or a part or an entry-level
or paid intern who knows whatever might
be now a lot of people and there's
actually laws against free interns in
certain states so it depends on where
you're at as well but I think that you
know if you feel like you don't have any
related experience and what your goal is
is to get experience you got to get that
experience any way you can a job search
takes three to six months on average
sometimes even longer and so what's
worse sitting around applying to jobs
and hearing no on everything because you
don't have enough experience and so you
spent three months not gaining
experience and not getting paid or three
months gaining experience even if you're
only getting paid a few dollars an hour
but gaining that experience putting that
on your resume and leveraging that for
the next role to get paid more I mean I
would rather you know do some free gigs
and gain that experience as a matter of
fact when I started coaching I started
coaching for free for years just to
build the skill set and it wasn't until
much later on that I started getting
paid for it so you know I was working in
marketing I had the ability to do that
but you know it's it's definitely
something to keep in mind
all right our next question from Ashwin
is it okay to follow up after an
interview to ask if you've gotten the
job or not just so you have a certain
answer hmm yes and no yes and no you
don't ever want to say did I get the job
because it's a yes-or-no question and
yes and no questions are typically
conversation Enders because you'll just
get a no so rather than saying and
really just break it down
psychologically when you say did I get
the job what you're saying is have you
done the thing that I want to do yet
have you given me what I want
have you decided to pay me money right
that's what we're asking we say did I
get the job rather and this is kind of
like a sales thing right rather we say
do you still need help are you still
looking for someone to fill this role
are there any other things that I can
help out with there's actually a story
of Udacity student who blogged about how
she you know she won't really want to
work at this one startup and she knew
she wanted to work there and she knew
what role she wanted to work in but she
they didn't have any openings in that
role so she said well what do you need
how can I help
she didn't say oh you can't give me a
job so I guess I'll move on she said all
right that job isn't a need that you
have right now what needs do you have
and I think they needed someone with
like just general admin work so she
started doing that and then they were
like oh we also need someone to like
help run these events and and whatever
and so she started helping with that and
then they were like oh actually our
we're doing really well we're gonna grow
our programming team she's like that's
what I really want I've already shown
that I can provide value imagine if I
was working on things that I cared about
so she got the job and so that's the way
you really want to think about these
things not did they give me a
no one has to no one owes you a job no
one has to give you anything unless you
show them why giving you a job helps
them so again you can't ask it but ask
it in a way that's helpful rather than
just trying to get your stuff settled
you know I hope that helps answer that
question all this is a great one Thank
You dev our our Deb's question is how
would you stay in touch in in the case
that the company rejected your
application all right so when you get
rejected what can you do the first thing
you want to do is ask what is the best
way to stay in touch and ask it to the
individuals at that company right
because like you know what's the best
way to follow up on future roles I don't
know look at the job boards make alerts
you know follow us on LinkedIn fair
enough but how do you actually follow up
with the people who you talk to those
are the critical people those are the
critical connections I really like to
keep in touch with people on LinkedIn
because it's hard to remember to follow
up with someone via email every three to
six months or something like that so
what you can do is say what's the best
way to follow up would you be open to
connecting over LinkedIn so now they're
in your network now just having them in
your network isn't a great way to follow
up because if they're in your network
and you're never on LinkedIn and you're
never doing anything
you're never interacting the thing
you're just like in their list of
thousands of contacts right so what you
want to do is you want to either follow
them or connect with them and then when
they post things like things comment on
things share things that reference their
industry I've even seen people go as far
as to tag people in posts that they
think are relevant you can also send
like hey you know we talked six months
ago I saw this really interesting
article related to something you're
working on thought I might share with
you there's a lot of different ways
keep in touch with people over time now
what you have to make sure you're
keeping in mind is like you don't want
to be weird you know you don't want to
be sending them you know message after
message after message right so if you go
back to that idea of like the the like
cadence of following up 24 hours one
week two weeks four weeks six weeks 12
weeks keep making it exponential maybe
you follow up at that cadence I know
people that work in sales and stuff they
you know send out like a yearly gift
around the holidays like a calendar
things like that there are so many ways
I would actually if you want to learn
more about this I would look at how to
keep leads warm just go to Google how to
keep leads warm as a sales person you're
gonna have tons and tons of strategies
out there but making it simple for you
best way to keep in touch connect with
them on LinkedIn like and comment on
their posts and share things that are
related to their industry so that it
pops up in their feet and they might
like it and comment and things like that
keeping it simple all right we're
getting towards the end here see if I
have time to answer any more all right
our last question here is going to be
from Sanjeev any advice on networking on
Twitter
based on my experience people that who I
target are more active on Twitter that's
awesome
Twitter's a fantastic place to connect
with people so what you can do is you
can follow people easy enough they work
at companies they are interested in
follow them no one's gonna say no to a
follower they may follow you back that's
cool if they're following you back and
you're tweeting they're gonna see that
if you're following each other you can
actually DM them and say like hey thanks
for following me you seem like you're
working on some interesting things would
you be open to grabbing coffee and
chatting now they're in your network now
you can continue to talk to them if
they're not following you back and you
can't send a DM
I have seen so many people just say like
hey I saw this position or people post
positions from their company online when
they posted send the message hey can I
shoot you an email and and and talk
about that yeah I would I I'm not as
well versed in Twitter to be honest so
I'm trying to think what other people
have seen do or what other people have
done and so typically from what I what I
understand about Twitter is that like
you can just talk to anyone so you can
say like hey you know you look like
you're doing some interesting stuff want
to connect on LinkedIn maybe Skype or
chat about your work so you watch you
know watch how you're doing it you don't
want to come off as weird I know that
there's also like dynamics between men
and women that get a little bit strange
online like people sending weird
messages via LinkedIn and stuff be
professional
all right be respectful be professional
and keep it on the point at hand talk
about the things that they're working on
see if you can help if you can be
helpful people want your help that's it
at the end of the day so let's end there
thank you all for joining the chat I
apologize for the technical issues at
the beginning and the confusion over
links you know Google Hangouts and
YouTube live and all these things get a
little bit tricky every once in a while
we have another event coming up next
Thursday so we'll be putting that link
in the chat right now for you to sign up
and register I believe there's a bit of
a glitch on the page that says it's on
Wednesday but I can assure you it is on
Thursday next week at the same time as
today and so we will be sending out more
information about that so feel free to
sign up thank you so much for joining us
if you're joining us for you know a
second third fourth time thank you for
following along it's been awesome
answering your questions if you're new
to us please join us next time and bring
even more amazing questions I hope to
get to all of them as we go through and
I wish you the best of luck in your job
search
thank you again and have a great rest of
the day
you